[Music]
Vsauce Kevin here on planets Mars
simulated Mars an eerie and otherworldly
corner of the world located on the
barren slopes of the Monell eval Kano in
Hawaii
national Geographics upcoming show Mars
details the realities of colonizing the
Red Planet and I partnered with them to
talk about the future of living in a
place like this after 12 months of
seclusion six scientists not quite
astronauts but lava knots have emerged
from studying what life on an inhabited
Mars might be like how do we keep our
bodies functioning in a place not meant
for us more importantly a hundred and
forty million miles from Earth's gravity
oxygen and family how do we keep our
minds functioning the Hawaii space
exploration and analog simulation or
high seas is a geodesic dome with around
1,300 square feet of livable space
designed for six scientists a two-way
software imposed 20-minute delay on
communication mimics the speed of light
message restriction between Mars and
Earth amenities include a dining area a
kitchen a bathroom and exercise area and
six bedrooms leaving the habitat or hab
for short
requires a hazmat suit which simulates
the encumbering spacesuit needed for
performing geology related tasks on Mars
on actual Mars astronauts will need
spacesuits for warmth and oxygen as well
as pressure the thin atmosphere on Mars
would cause earthling eyeballs skin and
lungs to try out like a lot since it
costs $10,000 per pound to blast things
into space survival items are kept to a
bare minimum everything needs to be
recycled filtered urine waters plants
and lights of optimal wavelength help
them grow a day's worth of Sun charges
batteries for a day and a half of power
there's composting toilets a pedis
ichael charges small devices like iPads
and the clean water used for their
30-second showers becomes grey water
used to
the floor primary funding for high seas
for came from the NASA behavioral health
and performance element they want to
find out how crews adapt to each other
under such stressful confined and
isolated environments board games help
bonding and mental stimulation musical
instruments like on Jays guitar and
Shea's didgeridoo help the lava not stay
connected to culture plush animals like
raspberry in trouble can substitute for
real pets and bring moments of levity to
a serious situation every little way to
boost morale is vital because once
humans leave the planet even things that
bring joy can also bring sadness
astronauts frequently cite being able to
see the earth as one of their most
rewarding beautiful experiences but
seeing earth as a tiny insignificant dot
can increase sensations of distance and
loneliness and this overview effect can
also inspire crews to focus on the
importance of protecting their planet
exploring is complicated we don't know
what's beyond the horizon like that one
kid in kindergarten someone's always
willing to taste the crayon the word
pioneer comes from the old French panera
meaning foot soldier the first people to
face danger from prehistoric times to
Paradise Nevada humans have constantly
pushed their boundaries but while over
90 percent of the ocean remains
unexplored we are enchanted by life
among the stars in 1865 Jules Verne's
from the earth to the moon suggested we
fire men out of a huge cannon to launch
them into space we developed rocket
propulsion instead and the challenge now
is to figure out how to live beyond
Earth's atmosphere that starts with
finding the right people the kind of
person then on the day of being the
first human launched into space was the
one calming everyone else down on the
day of the launch the head of the Soviet
space program said of space pioneer Yuri
Gagarin during the days of preparation
of the launch when everyone had more
than his share of concerns apprehensions
and anxieties he alone seemed to keep
calm more the
that he was full of good spirits and
beamed like the Sun Yuri was in space
for an hour and 48 minutes an
unbelievable accomplishment at a time
when scientists weren't sure whether
eyeballs would warp in zero-gravity and
make astronauts blind but it's not even
enough time to watch Star Wars and 1969
space race winning manned moon landing
mission Apollo 11 took just over eight
days total or 96 viewings of Star Wars
Episode four a new hope then the point
is the current record for longest
consecutive time spent in space is held
by Valery Polyakov aboard the space
station Mir clocking in at four hundred
and thirty seven point seven days Mars
could be a three-year trip it's roughly
nine months each way if we launch when
Earth and Mars are closest in their
respective orbits and in time spent on
the surface and if three years living in
the most unnatural and isolated
environment ever attempted by humans and
we're no stranger to making ourselves
strangers searching for new lands
requires a fearless portion of the
species to venture out into unknown
territory to be curious and to take
action
Clara ma 12 year old girl in Kansas gave
the Mars rover Curiosity its name saying
that curiosity is the passion that
drives us through our everyday lives and
those of us who stay behind revell and
hearing the stories of the curious tales
of great adventure date back to one of
humanity's oldest stories Homer's
Odyssey an eighth century BC epic poem
documenting Odysseus's ten-year journey
home after the Trojan War which includes
having a Cyclops toss half a mountain
Adam contending with the lore of the
sirens and fighting off the six-headed
monster Scylla despite all that he made
it home and with Greek monsters behind
us we look forward to conquering a
planet named for a Roman god baby steps
from leaving the atmosphere to walking
on the moon to entering Mars informed by
what we've learned from the solitude of
pioneers and prisoners
1862 Homestead Act which granted
settlers 160 acres of land about twice
the size of Disneyland separated people
from each other and long harsh winters
seem to erase all plant and animal life
Prairie madness cause depression
increased violence and even total mental
breakdown things got really lonely in
the Little House on the Prairie on sea
things get even lonelier calendar was a
feverish delirium afflicting sailors in
the tropics that could manifest in
picturing the water as a grassy meadow
and diving overboard traveling to
Earth's most remote reaches of
Antarctica reveals solitude that hurts
Australian meteorologist Martin boys who
spent ten weeks alone in Queen Maryland
wrote in 1912 the silence is so painful
now that I have a continual singing in
my left ear much like a barrel organ
only it's the same tune if the sound of
silence is painful what happens when
you're caught off from your own senses a
1951 study at McGill University that
would never be approved today looked at
the effects of solitary confinement a
method of punishing prisoners it was
scheduled to last six weeks it was
abandoned after wond in a room with only
a bed subjects wore goggles and
earphones to limit their senses they
reported being unable to think clearly
about anything for any length of time
those who could think became mentally
trapped hallucinating about things like
eyeglasses and dogs in a tiny room and
controlled conditions monitored by
researchers they were lost in themselves
seemingly simple tests can go haywire
and isolation when French geologist
Michels Sofia resurfaced after eight
weeks under a glacier in the French Alps
it took him five minutes to count 120
seconds and sociologist Mauricio
multi-beam II spent a full
year inside a cavern designed by NASA to
study isolation he thought it was only
219 days somehow in that cave 146 days
were lost without social and
environmental cues time begins to
stretch and warp so for space travel
were working on ways to preserve the
mind a dinner table was requested by
astronauts on the International Space
Station so they could build camaraderie
and be comforted by eating together
music is so important to combat cultural
isolation but since Apollo 15 in 1971
nASA has beamed songs into space as
wake-up calls we need to share joke
songs and struggles with others to keep
a connection to earth and to ourselves
otherwise we could become like mr.
Bedford and HG Wells 1901 book the first
men in the moon whose journey into
infinite space included experiencing a
sort of idea that really I was something
quite outside not only the world but all
worlds and out of space and time and
that this poor Bedford was just a peep
hole through which I looked at life the
basic survival elements on earth air
food shelter can be recreated in space
we can science our way to life on Mars
but only if our humanity arrives intact
the break off effect first documented in
a 1957 study of high-altitude pilots is
defined by a profound dissociation from
reality that can occur high above Earth
18 of the 137 pilots freaked out with
intense feelings of fear and anxiety but
the majority reacted with a previously
unknown sense of euphoria a newfound
understanding of the oneness of the
planet humanity and all creation
when alexei leonov returns to earth
after being the first human to float
freely in space during a 12 minute and
nine second spacewalk in 1965 he
responded to concerns for his mental
health by saying as for the so called
psychological barrier that was supposed
to be insurmountable by man preparing to
confront the cosmic abyss alone i not
only did not sense any barrier but even
forgot that there could be one
conquering our mental space is crucial
for surviving in outer space the journey
to Mars starts with the planet behind
your eyes and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
special thanks to National Geographic
for sponsoring this episode and
supporting Vsauce be sure to check out
their global event series Mars